it's almost like you look at at a
picture it's like you're almost not the
same you're that's not the same person
but you it is clearly it is it is but
it's like wait a minute is was that me
or is that the same person and then you
realize oh it's different now but I know
you mean about like well then you get
into Behavioral Systems and wiring and
like and then we just we could we would
have to do another inside yeah inside
inside of your but actually but that's
kind of what you're doing Michael I mean
you're going this road this journey of
what's inside of you and sharing it so
yeah you know I think the vulnerability
of that you know I think vulnerability
is probably a key thing isn't it